foreign
[Music]
lovers will get plenty of their money's
worth in the near future in this
original we present you all the great
action movies that await us this year
and in 2024. this much we can already
tell there are some awesome highlights
Denzel Washington returns in the final
part of The Equalizer Trilogy as a tough
ex-agent Roger McCall and settles up
with the mafia McCall has retired to
Italy after the events of the equalizer
2 and is enjoying the last years of his
life on the beautiful Mediterranean Sea
when a family friend of his gets into
trouble with the mafia he steps in one
last time to protect them the first
trailer promises badass action and a
Relentless Denzel Washington as we've
come to expect from the previous Parts
The Equalizer 3 will hit theaters on
September 1st 2023
The Expendables return in September this
reunion of well-known action Stars
returns with its fourth installment and
takes us on another mission this time
the mercenaries around Barney Ross have
to deal with a weapons dealer in his
army the familiar faces Jason Statham
Sylvester Stallone Randy Couture and
Dolph Lundgren are of course back for
the movie but newcomers like 50 Cent
Megan Fox Tony jaw and iko's wise will
also be part of the mission the release
trailer showcases typical Expendable
style through and through explosive
action bold sayings and edgy characters
we are looking forward to the new
adventure The Expendables 4 is scheduled
for release on September 22nd 2023.
with the Creator we get to enjoy a new
science fiction film from Rogue one
director Gareth Edwards the movie takes
us into a dystopian World in which
humans fight a fierce battle against an
artificial intelligence in this fight is
also ex-agent Joshua who is supposed to
go on a quest to find the so-called
Creator an AI developer who is in
possession of a mysterious weapon with
it they should succeed in ending the war
but at the same time they could also
Wipe Out the entire human race Denzel
Washington's son John David Washington
will play the main character the movie
comes with impressive visuals a gloomy
atmosphere and thrilling action is the
next science fiction Masterpiece waiting
for us let's find out for ourselves on
September 29 2023 the day the Creator
opens in theaters
in November the time will finally come
the sequel to The Evil news science
fiction epic Dune will be released on
the big screen the story of Dune 2 picks
up directly from part one Paul and his
mother find shelter with the desert
people of the Freeman Paul gets to know
their culture and in the process becomes
more and more of a prophet who will
Liberate the people but at the same time
plunge the universe into a great War a
final battle against the harkonin is
imminent the first images seem to
promise an epic conclusion to the story
about the desert planet we hope that
Dune 2 will actually make it to theaters
as planned on November 3rd 2023. there
are already rumors that the film might
be postponed due to the ongoing strikes
so keep your fingers crossed
Marvel presents us with another new
superhero adventure towards the end of
the year the plot of the Marvels built
on the MCU series one division Ms Marvel
and secret Invasion and presents us with
a body swap story between Kamala Khan
Carol Danvers and Monica Rambo every
time the three use their powers they
swap places unexpectedly this promises a
lot of chaos and funny moments between
the characters the cast includes Brie
Larson tiona Paris and Iman villani
Samuel L Jackson however will also
return in his role of Nick Fury we can't
wait to see what impact the quirky
Adventure will have on the future of the
MCU the Marvels is set to premiere on
November 10th 2023.
Jason Momoa will bring the 2023 movie
year to a close as Aquaman however the
sequel to the 2018 hit is ill-fated
originally the film was supposed to be
released in theaters in 2022 but was
later postponed to March 2023 due to
several additional shoots but even then
a release didn't happen instead it was
pushed back again to December 2023. the
reasons were partly due to the negative
reactions of test audiences to early
screenings and the chaos surrounding the
appearance of Batman who was first
supposed to return in the form of
Michael Keaton and then again in the
form of Ben Affleck ultimately however
both versions were cut from the film
likewise there is another possible
postponement due to the actors and
writer strike therefore all we can do is
wait and see whether Aquaman in the lost
kingdom will actually be released in
theaters on December 20th 2023
in 2024 two Cinema Giants Godzilla and
King Kong will meet again the
action-packed Godzilla vs Kong which was
released as part of the monsterverse
caused a stir among fans at the
beginning of 2021 and is now set for
another installment Adam Wingard who
already directed the previous part will
once again be responsible for the
direction not too much is known about
the story yet according to distributor
Warner Brothers it should be about the
common fight of Godzilla and Kong
against an unknown threat likewise we
will get new insights into the origin
story of the two Titans epic battles
should thus be guaranteed Godzilla X
Kong the new Empire will be released on
March 15 2024.
with Deadpool 3 the big mouth superhero
finally returns to the big screen he'll
be supported by fan favorite Wolverine
played of course by Hugh Jackman the new
adventure of the ah Duo should
definitely cause chaos in the Marvel
Universe and lead to the fact that we
get to see many familiar characters
again so it was announced that even
Jennifer Garner will return to her role
as Elektra there is speculation about a
possible appearance of new X-Men or the
Fantastic Four which could be introduced
into the MCU with Deadpool 3. it was
also revealed that the new part will be
given an R rating and will therefore be
quite violent again sadly there is a lot
of confusion about the release date
after the movie was only brought forward
recently to May 3rd 2024. Disney has now
put the theatrical release of Deadpool 3
on hold for the time being so it remains
to be seen when we will finally be able
to enjoy the unequal Duo together on the
big screen
oh what a day what a lovely day well it
looks like May 24 2024 will be a
wonderful day that's when we will
finally be able to enjoy the much
anticipated prequel to The Action hit
Mad Max Fury Road the prequel furiosa
will deal with the backstory of the
character of the same name who is
portrayed by Charlize Theron in the
first movie now Anya Taylor Joy is
slipping into the role and as the
younger version gets to show whether she
can be just as tough as her predecessor
we will also get to see Thor star Chris
Hemsworth in one of the main roles
additional movies from the Mad Max
Universe are already being planned after
the prequel so action fans can prepare
themselves for a lot but one step at a
time first of all we're looking forward
to the theatrical release of furiosa on
May 24 2024.
we will soon Return to the Planet of the
Apes the fourth part Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes will be set a few
years after the third installment War of
the Planet of the Apes and will focus on
the conflict between multiple eight
communities the new part is likely to
have a similarly dark and dramatic
setting as its predecessors Freya Allen
known from the Witcher series will be
part of the cast and embody a female
human filming was already concluded in
February 2023 so nothing should stand in
the way of the planned release of
kingdom of the Planet of the Apes on May
24 2024.
ballerina is the first movie spin-off
from the John Wick Universe on a dearmus
will play the eponymous ballerina who is
on a vendetta against her family's
murderers she is likely to encounter
some well-known faces from the previous
John Wick movies Keanu Reeves will also
return in his role of the popular Hitman
is believed to be a mentor of sorts to
ballerina the Len Wiseman directed
action film opens in theaters on June
7th 2024. if you want to know more about
ballerina check out our movie preview
the bad boys are returning in 2024 once
again Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
have been working as cops in the
franchise since 1995 and have taken on
the most insane missions in 2020 they
last made a grand comeback with bad boys
for life which grossed over 400 million
dollars worldwide it should therefore
come as little surprise that Columbia
Pictures has commissioned another part
in response to the success in addition
to Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
Vanessa Hudgins Alexander Ludwig and
Paula Nunez will be back they were
introduced as a new team and competitors
to the bad boys in the third part as in
the predecessor the brothers Adil
el-arbi and Below falal will direct the
film Bad Boys 4 will be released on June
14th 2024.
one last mission and then Ethan Hunt's
team will have an uncertain future with
Mission Impossible 8. the highly
acclaimed action series starring Tom
Cruise will reach its climax after many
years the new part will follow on
smoothly from Mission Impossible 7.
present us with the final battle against
the so-called entity unfortunately the
first half of the two movies fell
somewhat short of financial expectations
as the huge hits Barbie and Oppenheimer
opened it just a week later and
attracted all of the attention among
both fans and critics however part 7 was
certainly loved and therefore the final
mission is expected to be eagerly
awaited as well due to the current
strikes production is sadly at a
standstill although the movie has
already been shot for the most part the
predecessor already had to be postponed
time and again due to the pandemic so
fingers crossed let's hope that mission
impossible 8 will be released as planned
on June 28th 2024.
fans of the anti-hero Venom can finally
look forward to another installment
Venom kicked off Sony's Spider-Man
universe in 2018 and was a huge success
fans weren't really thrilled with the
sequel released in 2021 however while
they continued to see the casting of Tom
Hardy as an excellent choice they
criticized the lack of seriousness and
brutality of the comics nothing is known
about the story of Venom 3 yet there is
at least some speculation that the
anti-hero might meet Spider-Man after
all Eddie Brock was introduced to the
Multiverse in the post-credits scene of
no way home filming began in June of
this year but like many Productions it
is currently on Hiatus the anticipated
theatrical release date for Venom 3 is
July 12 2024.
with Captain America 4 Brave New World
Sam Wilson will finally get his own solo
Adventure as the new Captain America
like Captain America 2 the movie will be
more of a thriller and focus on the
conflict between Sam Wilson and the
leader in addition to Anthony Machias
Captain America the movie will also
feature Harrison Ford who will succeed
William hurt's role of Thaddeus Ross Liv
Tyler Rosa Salazar and Tim Blake Nelson
will also be part of the cast the fourth
film will not be directed by the Russo
Brothers this time but by Julius Ona who
has so far been able to impress with
rather smaller Productions Captain
America 4 will be out in theaters on
July 26 2024
besides Venom another Spider-Man villain
awaits us Craven the hunter was
originally supposed to be released in
2023 but was postponed to 2024 last
minute this did dampen the Euphoria of
the fans Yet the movie about Aaron
Taylor-Johnson as the protagonist Craven
is still being awaited with some
excitement the movie centers on Craven a
big game hunter who is considered one of
Spider-Man's best known antagonists the
GC Chandra directed movie has been given
an R rating and the first images promise
some bloody and badass action in
addition to Aaron Taylor Johnson Russell
Crowe Christopher Abbott and Ariana
Dubose will also join the cast after the
postponement Craven the hunter will now
open in theaters on August 30th 2024.
with Thunderbolts we get the suicide
squad equivalent from Marvel the movie
focuses on a group of mercenaries who
have already been introduced in previous
productions for instance there's the
super soldier John Walker played by
Wyatt Russell who already played a
central role in Falcon in the Winter
Soldier or black widow's sister Yelena
Bulova played by Florence Pugh in
addition to the two other prominent
names are joining the film's cast among
others the cast features Olga Kurylenko
as Taskmaster Sebastian Stan as Bucky
Barnes David Harbor is Red Guardian The
Walking Dead star Stephen young and
Harrison Ford the Thunderbolts are
considered anti-adventures and are
expected to embark on a particularly
daring Mission much like the suicide
squad we wonder above all whether Daniel
bruel will also return in his role of
Baron Zemo after all he was the founder
of the group in the comics the mission
of the Thunderbolts is set to open in
cinemas on December 20th 2024.
and that's it those are the upcoming
action-packed movies in 2023 and 2024.
what are your thoughts on the announced
releases and which movie are you looking
forward to the most let us know in the
comments and be sure to like the video
If you enjoyed it thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign